[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka the definition
decoy
and as every little bit helps when it
comes to understanding rick and morty
we've put together a breakdown of the
best easter eggs hidden details and
things you missed from season 5 episode
3.
now the entry introduces the new
character planeteena who is clearly
playing on the superhero captain planet
the ecomaniac from the 90s in case you
kids aren't as old as your uncle paul
and you might not remember him growing
up but i was absolutely obsessed with
the cartoon
after the destruction that humans had
dealt on the planet gaia sent several
rings to do-gooders
known as planeteers these all possessed
certain abilities in them
such as the power to control air water
wind and dirt
[ __ ] magnets how do they work they
all had their own unique things
but together they could summon captain
planet he's a hero
now captain planet in the planet ears
would travel around the earth cleaning
up oil spills
stopping corporations from cutting down
the rainforest and they were just sort
of
greta thumbberg with a video game now
almost every episode would end with cap
telling us
the power is yours and this is something
that we see planetina say to morty
her music also uses the same chord
progression that his theme had
and she speaks in rhyme every time which
gives me acid pain
we even see the cartoon intro for
planetina at one point and this is
clearly pulling several
elements they from the original work
voiced by alison brie
planetena does a great job of saving the
planet but as always greed twists the
message to have it be a certain way
now this episode opens with rick and
morty coming out of johnny d's custom
tees
with some brand new personalized merch
this has their face on it with the
caption [ __ ] pounders
which i think might be a reference to
the posse patrol from the in-betweeners
however it's just something utter lads
like us call ourselves when we're
out and about blood [ __ ] [ __ ] now in
the window we can also see a nod to mr
meeseeks
who first appeared in season one episode
five i think that's also what looks like
the chest of a teenage mutant ninja
turtle
which of course was also a cartoon from
the 90s now speaking of 90s cartoons
we get a nod to what i think might be
biker mice from mars with the arrival of
diesel weasel
in case you don't know this show sended
around three mice traveling to earth
from mars
in order to save the planet their bikes
could ride across space and spread
pollution throughout the galaxy
yay now i never thought of how cartoons
would interact when i was a kid growing
up
but as we live in the world of shared
universes now
it's nice to see rick and morty having
these parodies go head to head
i also feel like he's based slightly on
splinter from ninja turtles
but let me know below if you disagree a
diesel weasel brings with him acid rain
and not only does this burn morty's skin
but it also starts to mess up the brand
new custom
tees i love how morty khan opened the
ship door as he pulls the handle just as
rick unlocks it
and this is no doubt something we've all
experienced when trying to get into a
car quickly
now we did say in our last breakdown
that rick had been missing the typical
drool that he had in the show
and that he also hadn't been burping
because of this it seemed like the guy
had gone t
total however after learning of the
decoys last week
it seems like the one in the first
episode may have been a doppelganger
as this rick is back and he's drinking a
tall boy from foamies
however he did go into space but either
way the drool is now back
now morty starts cleaning up a can
outside and this catches the attention
of planeteena
morty is on it until he vomits and is
clearly interested in her
as we can see him covering up the [ __ ]
pounder logo
morty asks if she wants to go and get
some ice cream but she won't because
veal is part of the dairy industry
however
she knows a place where they can get
some guilt-free donuts and they fly off
and that's the opening covered and if
you're enjoying this video then please
smash the thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe to never
miss a breakdown on the show
if you don't i'll get your next slime
and the power
is yours to watch more videos i i guess
now the episode is called a rick
convenient mort which is based on the
documentary an inconvenient truth by al
gore
this was created to bring more attention
to global warming and due to winning
oscars it's probably the most famous one
out there
this was parodied in the south park
episode man bear pig
which had gore trying to warn people
about well man bear pig
now after the titles we cut to morty
telling his family about planeteena
and summer is pretty angry as she's
being dumped by taylor murphy before his
big pool party
summer says that morty is stating a face
for superhero
which is of course a note of the mcu and
morty actually ends up a bit like thanos
by the end of the episode
as he collects the four elemental rings
from the tina tiers
knowing that mori is now all loved up
rick comes up with a ridiculous trip
that he and summer can have some fun on
this involves traveling to three planets
that are about to go through their own
apocalypse
and there's several nod theater films
such as the black hole from interstellar
as well as the asteroid from deep impact
rick was already clearly planning this
as we can see that he's added a ponytail
to morty on the [ __ ] pounder's tee
and has also written summer over the top
of his name i love how we can also see
the acid rain stains in it and a
these guys they've got some good
attention to detail now jerry also tries
to stop her
and she says he can suck her bigger dick
she also has some 2010 new year's eve
glasses
which might have been the last time that
she partied after not getting a text
back from planet
morty heads out to a wildfire and here
he comes face to face with her
and the tina tiers who are now older and
just doing the entire thing is a pr
stunt
this is clearly commenting on the
criticism that a lot of eco-friendly
strategies have been adopted by
companies doing the bare minimum
but they know that it gains them
positive traction in the media
interestingly out of the original lineup
of the tina tiers the heart ring is
missing
showing why they don't have one
planeteena is also made to wear a vote
no to prop 6 t-shirt
which according to google means that she
was voting to keep fuel tax increases
the kids clearly control her entire
image and have lost their do good aside
in order to commercialize the idea of
her
more he announces that they're dating
and we could to reckon summer
the former of which initially hates love
but he does find it in a more glazian
named daphne
hello now on the first small glacier
that he chats up we can see a hint of
the elbow titties
but they're just not as good as daphne's
morty received some flowers made out to
look like his head
and over the episode these weather and
die much like the love between the pair
planetina also says zhing ho won't let
her watch the news
showing that the tina tiers control
every aspect of her life
however she sneaks out after saying she
was recycling some batteries
and we get a lovely animated section
that has dolphins and butterflies
in it which is an opposite to her 90s
cartoon
now back with mrs obama sorry summer
they head off the planet
but we learned that whilst she was
willing to ditch the clingers
rick wasn't the planet is engulfed in
the supernova and cut to ecocon
which is clearly going to be causing a
lot of pollution due to it being a big
convention
planeteena is warped in with morty
attached to her and though she's sent
out there
morty is escorted into a back room this
clearly ruins the presentation but to
distract from it
the teenage years a limited edition
funko pops exclusive to the con
which i will buy all of them mate now we
cut to the second planet
and summer is smoking a cigarette
through her nose and it's clear she's
been ditched by rick
as he's now hooked up with daphne in the
back room morty ends up killing the
first planeteer
and he takes their ring which allows him
to wield fire cut to the rest of the
group selling off the character to a
baby seal eating man
that is an individual character who
represents no group
morty arrives wearing a murder pipe eats
a delivery uniform to free planeteena
from them
and he brutally kills them all the seals
even get to eat
and it looks like planeteena is finally
going to be able to save the planet on
her own terms however she
ends up becoming a bit of an extreme
activist that's willing to flatten
people's tyres
and set fire to homes we see rick summer
and daphne leaving the second planet
which is being sucked into a black hole
that as we mentioned earlier
uses the same design as the one from
interstellar they've knocked a curtain
up and
daphne and summers spend some time
together where we learn about dem
elbow titties let's be real men we're
only after one thing
those god damn elbow titties god damn
now i tried looking for an uncensored
version uh purely for research purposes
but i couldn't find it so let me know
below if you saw one
uh and and also send the link yes send
the link
now daphne says they've inspired
presidents and ruined regimes
and rick is addicted to the elbow grease
so she's gonna be around for a while it
seems
at morty's the family play the board
game don't punch my lunch with planet
but beth doesn't approve of their
relationship because morty's 14 which
yeah
is a bit weird now we get a musical
montage to the song
i am the antichrist to you by
kishibashin in which planeteena stops
hunters and goes super saiyan on some
miners
she loves doing stuff with miners hey
it's a really really bad joke that one
now oh no she also flies morty up into
the clouds
which is playing on the scene from the
first superman film in which clark did
the same thing with lois
after she destroys the entire operation
we cut to ferkis nine
and see one of the hot dog looking
aliens saying that the sex he's having
with his dad is terrific
summer ends up stopping this planet from
being destroyed and in the post-credits
scene we have a very awkward exchange
between these two as we learn their
mother and wife isn't talking to them
because of this moment summer flies up
in a great one shot
and interestingly the lasers that she
shoots out at the asteroid
all pull from the same colours that the
rings of the tina tears have
this shows how rick's journey echoes
morty and again
it's like poetry they rhyme now summer
wants to head home but daphne doesn't
want to go with them
and she says goodbye this is of course
been set up the entire episode because
she said hello quite a lot so is it good
writing i'm not sure but
it was a nice little joke now rick is
furious but he thinks that
what summer did was pretty rick and the
bear bond over what they've gone through
planet and morty break up but much like
summer was there for rick
beth is there for her son planetina
flies off
and i hope that one day we get her back
as there is some unfinished business
with her
now as for the episode as a whole i know
from the comments on the last two videos
that a lot of you have been mixed on
this season
but so far i've really enjoyed it last
week was kind of a standalone thing that
i know some people felt was filler but i
love it when the show just takes things
in a direction that you can't really
predict
so far i think we've had three good
episodes and it's going to be
interesting to see if the show keeps up
this consistency with the level of
issues that
pretty much everything would have had
production wise over the last year
still though another good one that felt
like a trip through my childhood in
which we walked down memory lane
and took a dump on everything i held
dear i had a blast and obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on it
so make sure you comment below and let
me know as a thank you for interacting
with the video you'll be entered into a
prize show on the 30th of july
in which we randomly pick three comments
that can win an mcu box set of their
choice
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our brighton of the bad
batch which will be linked on screen
right now
we've gone over the entire 10th episode
and pointed out all the easter eggs we
could find
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more without the way
thank you for singing through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace